the German capital is decked out for the
holiday gendarmenmarkt square is
dazzling after its festive makeover so
are the world famous Brandenburg Gate
and the city's magnificent shopping mall
the kurfürstendamm during the pre
Christmas season it's a popular place to
stroll among locals and tourists alike
it's home to the city's number-one
shopping destination the cow-house des
residents known meit's acronym car they
they arguably the most famous department
store in Germany car today is also one
of the biggest in Europe
every year the lobby is transformed into
a wintry Wonderland
this year's theme is a Christmas journey
through the world cities Paris st.
Petersburg and London the focus is on
stylish decorations and ornaments
and of course Santa Claus is also here
excited children can hand him their wish
lists right up until Christmas Eve and
for those who asked nicely he's happy to
pose for a photo
let's call me I feel annoyed you come
lots of people just come by to say hello
to Santa Claus
Martin - man Hallows
Cartier's Santa Claus has fans from all
over the world who come to see him when
they're in town family visits to the
theater are popular in the pre Christmas
period fairy tales are performed in this
wooden hut in the center of Berlin there
are up to five performances a day and in
the interval audience members can warm
up by the fire or enjoy a hot drink
the producer Kristian Schultz says the
shows are for audiences of all ages he
making [ __ ] LED first they were meant
for children but we realized more and
more adults were coming to the late
shows now we still have a lot of
performances for children but even more
for adults but we're not the ones who
discovered that the pre Christmas period
is a time for fairy tales Zambia for the
repertoire features classics such as
Sydnor Anna it's Snow White or Hansel
and Gretel set inside a gingerbread
house in the forest it's a seasonal
favorite
that's him became young the actors are
all at liberty to give their own
interpretations of the story naturally
there's a happy ending and the audience
is satisfied
don't know about my kids but I liked it
fine very nice I really liked it
Christmas markets are another
unmissable tradition
Berlin has some 60 to choose from one of
the most popular is the Jean Tom and
mark square it draws about 600,000
visitors a year from all over the world
and many of them like eating bratwurst
from the touring and region they're
flavored with marjorie and caraway and
the recipes over 600 years old
view vine or mulled wine is a Christmas
market special flavored with cloves
cinnamon and anise seed it tastes as
good as it smells and it's a surefire
recipe for a cheer visit the Christmas
market is an indispensable part of the
holiday season the year is drawing to a
close it's nice to gather with friends
over a glass of mulled wine
after refreshments at a Christmas market
it's time for a stroll along the coast
and am stretching three and a half
kilometres it's lights can be enjoyed
until early January
you